[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much
so you remember Richard Dreyfus right
the oscar-winning actor from such
Classics as American Graffiti jaws and
this interview with Bill Maher with him
sliding off a chair
like in those days of the studios
Temple's book who Shirley Temple Shirley
Temple when you read her book you can
read between the lines oh of an enormous
uh
um
well a scandal that never unscandalized
she was abused
oh yeah
understand chairs
he sits like Alec Baldwin shoots
too soon I'm sorry anyway
apparently he's pissed off about how
mandatory diversity is destroying movies
and this weekend on Firing Line he
slammed a new diversity inclusion
inclusion requirements for films in
order to be considered for Academy
Awards it's part of Hollywood's quest
for a rainbow of stars who can now slap
Chris Rock
starting in 2024 best picture contenders
must have at least one of the lead
actors or supporting actors from an
underreported or unrepresented racial or
ethnic group in other words that Hitler
biopic better have some black Nazis
yeah and if it doesn't feature a
marginalized group then the storyline
itself must be focused on one like women
lgbtq or deaf people
in fact they already have a movie in the
can based on these new rules it stars
Marley Madden as Helen Keller who
teaches her black life partner played by
Tracy Morgan sign language through the
art of erotic hand signals
it's called Finger Licking Good
believe me the original joke was worse
this raises some questions though like
if you hire an actor with one or more
underrepresented characteristics will
that help the film company fill more
slots you know kill three birds with one
wheelchair-bound Cherokee drag queen
named Miss Sitting Bull makes sense
of well thank you of course somebody
choked over there this says nothing
about the film's quality which is
dreyfus's point I mean Jaws is awesome
but the only underrepresented character
eats people
I wonder if he thinks these new
inclusion standards for film make him
vomit
they make me vomit because
this is an art form no one should be
telling me as an artist
that I have to give in to the latest
most current idea of what morality is
and what are we risking are we really
risking hurting people's feelings
you can't legislate that
he's not wrong and he's sitting in a
chair for once
but I know he's right because I speak
from experience I tried telling one
artist what to do
and then she wrote this song
[Music]
uh who needs her her CPAP machine was so
loud
what but maybe you have to let life be
life
you have to let life be life and I'm
sorry I don't think that there's a
minority or a majority in the country
that has to be catered to like that
couldn't agree more I mean I'm short and
I don't get mad when I lose roles that
were meant to me originally
and I bet you didn't know Lawrence
Olivier was the last white actor to play
Othello and he did it in blackface
Lawrence Olivier
was the last white actor to play Othello
in 1965 and he did it in blackface
and he played a black man
brilliantly
am I being told that I will never have a
chance
to play a black man
[Laughter]
yes you will never play a black man I
know it's hard try to try to soothe
yourself in that bathtub filled with
millions of dollars
because back then great white actors
taking on black roles was due to a
scarcity of black actors of course now
you have a plethora of black actors with
great dramatic range
but Hollywood doesn't just want to
mandate ethnic and gender diversity
among actors and crew but also sexual
orientation as if anyone's been to LA
and thought hey someone needs to gay
this place up
sorry for most most people in Hollywood
their sexual habits shouldn't mandate
jobs it should mandate community service
and how do you get that info from
applicants anyway you can't just scout
out bowling alleys to find lesbians
not after that court order
but more important by trade an actor
appropriates other people's lives that's
why it's called acting you shouldn't
have to get a serial killer to play a
serial killer
although that would be a great plot for
a movie every few days a crew member has
found stabbed to death you can call it
cut
sadly though you can't even strangle A
co-worker and say you were method acting
I get it though this inclusivity
nonsense might sound like a good idea
it's certainly a wonderful virtue signal
for Hollywood that temporarily hides The
Shame of the pervy past but it shouldn't
be mandated
just think what a movie about Harold
Ford Jr might be like
[Music]
elected to congress and loved by all
became a star on the five authoring an
epic tale of politics patriotism and sex
appeal
but this summer his Greatest Adventure
is yet to come
Fox Entertainment proudly presents the
Harold Ford Jr story
starring Greg Gutfeld as Harold Ford Jr
with a special appearance by a bag of
old coins as Jesse Watts
that'll win an Oscar
let's welcome tonight's guest he's known
for Reaching Across the aisle to tickle
me on bus rides co-host of the five
Harold Ford Jr
all right
it is first time guess has more
offensive lines in the NFL the comedian
and host of the stand up special dog
belly on YouTube Big Jay oakerson
his jokes are why his kids
tell people their father's dead
actor writer and comedian Jamie lissout
and you call it an
she calls it a fashion accessory Fox
News contributor captive
[Applause]
all right somebody get a doctor for that
lady hey Harold you know um I was with
him for a while until he said it was
offensive to him that he can't play a
black person is he speaking strictly
from being an actor and that or is he
just like missing uh how would you feel
how would you feel if he played you in
the Harold Ford Jr story I think it'd be
great I think one of the things that
he's missing and I thought Margaret
Hoover did a great job with him is that
they're not a lot of stories there's not
a lot of opportunities he didn't he
didn't miss out on roles because he
didn't get an opportunity to play an
African-American character in some Story
one of the things that's happened in
Hollywood and one of the things that's
happened I think in all of media is that
Margaret Hoover who's a great interview
and has a great show we get it you like
her Harold our kids our kids are in
school together but she I knew it but
but she here's the thing she couldn't
have done that show 20 30 40 years ago
the thing about Richard Dreyfuss he's
always been on the inside from the
standpoint that he at least had the
opportunity to compete for roles and he
had the opportunity to compete I think
for two reasons one of the stories were
written for more stories are in for
people like him and then two there was
some inherent racism now I think his
point about mandates and some of the
things some of the inclusivity things
have gone too far and you and I have had
that conversation in public and in
private as we talk about these things
but I think he needs to be mindful of
the fact that the more stories that are
written I actually dream of the day when
he gets denied to play a character that
happens to be black would you end up
other actors who who maybe white have
have because that's when you know that
we've reached a point where there's
equality in terms of the stories being
told and the roles being offered you
wanted to be a point of equality where
the shark would eat black people
absolutely because that's the thing with
jaws is there's no black people being
eaten right and he didn't and it was a
great white
could have been a great story
they had to redo jaw they had to redo
Jaws from a from a black perspective
Jamie you know Jamie you're kind of an
under underrepresented category you're
kind of a lonely divorced man in Alaska
it's pretty miserable I got some rules
coming to me I think you're right
um
you know what I learned uh I learned
from Dreyfus I learned old people don't
give up yeah yeah like when you get a
certain age you just say like whatever
you want and I'm kind of with you like I
was with him ever I do think people if
we if we have a person available that
could play themselves like why not do
that like you know about me everybody
knows like I used to like I delivered
pizzas like I was a pizza delivery guy
and so many times I'm watching a
pornographic movie and I'm like they
just threw someone in there you know to
act
and I think it might be good for you
know people watching to have a relatable
sized penis it's like
it's true does it always have to look
like the boom mic is is on screen
um but in all seriousness I think he
made some great points at the beginning
and movies are about being immersed in
the movie and have you ever had it where
like inclusion or it takes you out of
the movie yeah because you go there
doing this I was watching like there's a
movie this plane was like running out of
gas and the air traffic controller was
like a like a a guy with a dress on and
a mustache she was like you're getting
too close to the plane and I was like I
don't even care what happens to the
plane anymore I want to know about the
disaster that's running Air Traffic
Control
I'm like so interested I don't know I
just I think it hurts the yeah the
experience of the movie you want to like
watch the movie I don't want to think
about characters or acting I don't even
think about the lonely guys around me
with their codes over their laps
big J welcome to the show thank you for
having me my pleasure yo it's weird I
think like with something like this it's
okay to do diversity because they're not
operating on anybody you know what I
mean they're not flying planes but if
this bleeds into that then we're in
trouble yeah it's so weird though like
yeah it's not a skills position you have
to worry about but
it is strange like the the black face do
you remember
uh the Chuck Norris Super film Delta
Force part one yes
Robert Forster played a Palestinian
terrorist also in blackface yes now as a
Hollywood adjacent Jew like myself what
are we going to do hire an actual
Palestinian to do that job yeah that
sounds terrifying
so I don't know anything but also I
don't disagree with his points at all
however
maybe he's got to tell like maybe a
younger actor to pass these things off
when he was when he was sitting on his
back ass on the Bill Maher show he was
making some pretty good points but by
the time
I mean on the PBS show he was just get
off my lawn energy the whole time
so No One's Gonna Hear the points it
just sounds like a crotchy old man yeah
it's true it's true why didn't he say
this sooner that's the thing they'd wait
until the career is almost over a cat
and then suddenly they're speaking their
mind yeah by the way I've been racist
this whole time
the ultimate Shyamalan twist
that's a good idea for a movie it is the
Dreyfus has been racist this whole time
yes and some how do you say his last
name shamala land I always know
Shyamalan Shyamalan there you go I'm
guessing yes so cat what do you make of
this diversity inclusion BS as you can
judge by my question I think it's BS
yeah well I don't understand how it
doesn't come up more that some of this
seems like it could be a potential HR
violation right like the lgbtq stuff
when exactly does that come up in a job
interview like so you like music so who
do you like to bang is it guys is it
girls you mix it a little bit of both we
need to know because that determines
whether or not we hire you yeah that's
actually what you're asking people to do
I feel like that's pretty invasive and
it's under the guise of inclusion but I
feel like I would be pretty
uncomfortable in a situation like that I
think most people would be so I think
it's gone a little bit insane yeah so
you would have to judge a book by its
cover yeah or like you look gay is that
true are you gay yes I'm moving in
Hollywood I'd say throwing a flannel
yeah yeah exactly you're not reading
yeah
bring up leave a power tool in your
purse
laughs not that kind cat all right hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else